j'avais un dominique traquant merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors la france a donc déployé 1 2
rafale et des navires de la marine
nationale quel intérêt motive au fond
une intervention de la france dans cette
zone
d'abord remercie pour votre invitation
alors il ne faut pas voir l'intervention
de la france
isolé il s'agit d'une action européenne
avec une répartition des rôles entre
l'allemagne mal à merkel qui est
présidente de l'union européenne pour ce
semestre et la france madame merkel est
à l'action dans la négociation demain
doit se réunir les ministres des
affaires étrangères européens à
bruxelles
de façon à pouvoir trouver une manoeuvre
coordonnées j'allais dire sur le plan
diplomatique et la france elle a des
moyens en méditerranée puisque vous le
savez il ya pas mal de choses qui se
passent en méditerranée et elles
montrent que la force ne peut pas être
usée unilatéralement contre un pays de
l'union européenne
donc il s'agit bien d'action concertée
entre les deux alors on sait que les
relations entre ankara et paris sont
tendus emmanuel macron appelle ses
homologues à se concentrer à se
concerter davantage la turquie s'est
elle tournée vers l'allemagne et le
conseil de l'europe le déploiement
militaire français ne risque-t-il pas de
crisper davantage la situation ne leur
il faut pas inverser sais pas monsieur
erdogan qui a demandé c'est l'union
européenne qui est qui a décidé de se
saisir du de la faire vous le disiez
dans votre sujet il y a eu une
intervention des jeunes madame merkel
antérieur et qui a fait reculer en
quarts 1 est donc là il y à une
concertation européenne et il s'agit
simplement de montrer au président
erdogan qu'il a des moyens militaires
certes personne ne le conteste mais que
ce ne sont pas des moyens à utiliser
dans le différend qui oppose
actuellement la grèce et la turquie et
que la france comme les autres pays
européens sont solidaires de la grèce
pour essayer de résoudre ce problème de
façon diplomatique mais on est on agit
aussi j'allais dire un peu en mettant la
carotte et le bâton il faut bien avoir
montré aussi qu'on a les moyens nous
militaires qui pourraient s'opposer et
reste
permettent de rester solidaires avec la
grèce que la grèce ne se sentent pas
seuls dans cette crise et dans ce
contexte athènes et ankara peuvent-ils
trouver un accord justement pour sortir
de cette crise je l'espère bien
volontiers alors si vous voulez quand on
écoute le monsieur le discours de
monsieur erdogan
c'est un peu comique le que évidemment
que la mairie j'ai très compliqué
évidemment qu'il ya des îlots qui sont
très proches de la turquie ça ne fait
aucun doute c'est l objet d accord à la
fin de la première guerre mondiale mais
de là à dire que c'est à 525 km de la
grèce continentale ça dépend d'où vous
prenez le point d'origine
lio n'est pas à 5 124 km des côtes grecs
donc il faut absolument négocier ça
entre gens de bonne volonté il ya
maintenant des ressources importantes
qui suscite la cupidité bien sûr de part
et d'autre il faut trouver un accord
entre les deux pays
et quelle est la position de l'otan
vis-à-vis de ces deux états membres
grèce et turquie
vous avez raison de le souligner la
j'allais dire l'otan regarde ses
chaussures si j'ose dire
l'auteur n'ose pas trop intervenir parce
qu'elle tient beaucoup à ses deux alliés
que sont la grèce et la turquie est elle
préfère laisser l'europe traiter ce
sujet plutôt que de s'emparer de ce
sujet là et en ce qui concerne pour
revenir aux relations entre la france et
la turquie
on sait qu'elles sont tendues notamment
depuis s'effacer ces derniers mois
est-ce qu'elle ne risque pas
de se tendre encore davantage selon vous
non elles sont entendues depuis depuis
quelques mois vous avez raison de le
souligner aussi bien l'extérieur donc on
parle de la libye on parle de la crise
dont que nous évoquons ce soir que deux
de l'action des frères musulmans en
france donc elles sont tendus tout
naturellement
maintenant il faut bien voir que de la
part du président erdogan qui est en
mauvaise position il a des élections a
gagné pour l'instant il les a perdus l'a
perdu en quarts à il a perdu istanbul il
a une opposition qui se lève et donc il
a intérêt à susciter au sein de la
population turque un espèce de
regroupement autour de lui en montrant
qu'il est agressé que donc il faut
défendre la turquie donc je pense que
c'est plutôt un problème de politique
intérieure pour monsieur erdogan capot
dit-il utilise la politique extérieure
en vue de se ré asseoir correctement sur
l'échiquier électoral interne du roc
merci beaucoup de mythes trinquant
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien chef de la
mission militaire française à l'ol